[Música]
en octubre cumple 11 años en facebook 11
años es mucho tiempo
al principio estaba estudiando
comunicación y no sabía demasiado de qué
se trataba pero me pareció divertido
al poco tiempo empecé a ver que mis
bandas favoritas bandas independientes
se empezaban a difundir su música y me
pareció algo increíble
entonces cuando tuve que pensar en un
objeto de estudio para la tesis no lo
dude internet
y también al poco tiempo dije bueno
vamos a ver qué puedo hacer yo desde mi
lugar y así creé mi propio blog que fue
el primero y a partir de este blog
empecé a contar lo que hacía lo que me
pasaba lo que sentía
y empezó generando también oportunidades
del primer trabajo
de mi primera colaboración en un medio
regional
de poder trabajar en festivales de
entrevistar a mis ídolos varias veces
también y no solamente eso sino que uno
de ellos publicará un artículo de mi
blog en su facebook
también así participar en programas de
televisión nacional
colaborar en uno de mis medios favoritos
la edición local de una de las revistas
más importantes del mundo y finalmente
comenzar mi emprendimiento y estar acá
también después de internet de las redes
sociales y cuatro meses de práctica
porque salir de internet no es muy fácil
como
levanté la mano quiero usar redes
sociales
[Música]
y levante la mano quien hace esto
es algo bastante si hace diez años
preguntábamos que era hacer esto como
que nadie sabía muy bien que era como
aunque que sé hacer esto y levante la
mano quien siente que no tiene tiempo
la mayoría no
internet es increíble no sólo nos
permite comunicarnos con gente que está
lejos sino también nos permite conocer
cuestiones no ya sea información que de
otra forma no sería posible nos permite
enterarnos de cosas invisibilizadas por
medios tradicionales
pero sobre todo el avance tecnológico
del avance social nos permitió pasar de
ser consumidores a ser prosumidores esto
significa que consumimos y producimos
contenido en internet nosotros subimos
nuestras fotos escribimos nuestros
textos creamos nuestras cuentas y hoy en
día no solamente todos los que estamos
acá sino todas las personas del mundo
nos vamos de facebook qué pasa
no tiene sentido no estamos ahí por la
gente estamos ahí por nosotros
pero como todo tiene sus cuestiones
positivas y sus cuestiones no tan
positivas verdad
se dice hace mucho tiempo que la
comparación es una de las fuentes de
infieles infelicidad más grandes del
mundo pero también la comparación es
como generamos conocimiento
una de las cuestiones que nos genera
últimamente hay muchos estudios que se
pueden golear que hablan sobre como las
redes sociales nos condicionan en temas
de salud mental ansiedad depresión como
que es esta cuestión del miedo de
perdernos cosas ya sea por avances
tecnológicos que no podemos estar a la
par todo el tiempo o no podemos consumir
todo el tiempo o sea cosas que están
pasando paralelamente de las que no
somos parte
hay varios estudios pero uno de ellos
dice que por ejemplo instagram es la red
social que más perjudica nuestra auto
percepción no solamente de nuestro
cuerpo sino de nuestra vida
se ve que estoy instagram en algún
momento lo escucho y dijo bueno vamos a
hacer este experimento de ocultar los
likes y para qué sirve esto para
concentrarnos en producir contenidos que
nos gusta en vez de contenido que genere
más me gusta
a la par también surgen cuentas que
empiezan a desenmascarar estos supuestos
influencers
y nos muestran ya sean y los de twitter
cuentas de youtube vídeos
y nos muestran cómo modifican su rostro
y su cuerpo hasta quedar prácticamente
irreconocibles como dicen que asisten a
un evento súper exclusivo cuando en
realidad era abierta al público como
compran ropa y la usan solamente para
una foto de facebook cómo se casan para
tener más visibilidad visibilidad y
poder monetizar el streaming nos
muestran estas cosas y una vista pero
que no lo pensamos antes que lo que
estaba en internet no era quizás del
todo cierto es que en realidad una de
las pruebas más irrefutables que tenemos
los seres humanos es el sentido de la
vista y si lo vemos lo creemos las redes
sociales representan ficción es una foto
es un recorte de la realidad no es una
realidad en todo caso puede llegar a
mostrar un resultado pero no el proceso
no muestran si editamos nuestras fotos
si pagamos en 25 cuotas un viaje a
grecia y en el transcurso almorzamos
galletitas nos muestran si estuvimos
cinco años trabajando en un libro no
muestran si estuvimos años o inclusive
la noche preparando nuestra tesis no
nuestra nuestra presentación de la tesis
porque si hicimos la tesis de acá
sabemos que es difícil
y muestran el resultado y qué pasa
cuando mostramos el resultado y no el
proceso parece fácil no parece
instantáneo y si parece fácil y parece
instantáneo entonces por qué yo no
saben cuánto tiempo pasamos los
argentinos en internet
alguno se anima a dar un estimado 5
horas 4 horas 6 horas
cuánto
para acá
hay varios estudios todos julia bless
como toda la vida pero hay un estudio de
hootsuite y we are social que señala que
los argentinos pasamos en promedio 8
horas en internet por día y que
desbloqueamos el celular aproximadamente
unas 190 veces por día también
el año pasado presenté mi primer libro
que se llama escrito sin pacientes para
gente sin tiempo y está dedicado a
instagram
y el escritor del prólogo es una forma
de decir porque el escritor del prólogo
que es un gran amigo mío y una persona
que admiro mucho dice que en realidad
todo lo que tenemos es tiempo y no
solamente eso somos lo que hacemos con
nuestro tiempo
no tiene nada de malo hacer así es crear
pasar una hora en instagram en twitter
en facebook en donde quieran lo
importante es ser consciente que podemos
hacer ante tanta comparación tanta
ficción tanto que no sabemos muy bien
qué onda
es curar elegir curar internet curar el
contenido si lo que consumimos no nos
inspira no nos motiva no nos enseña no
nos entretiene entonces no tiene mucho
sentido
nosotros elegimos yo elijo vos elegís
nosotros elegimos
somos prosumidores en internet y en la
vida real
[Aplausos]
[Música]